[Music]
good design architecture comes with your
inner vision
it can positively influence communities
and Foster social interaction good
design has the potential to reflect
Elevate and shape the cultural identity
of a society
[Music]
I'm Kenny from Canada Architects I've
been running a practice for nearly 20
years now since I come back from London
I
noticed that better buildings better
architecture better designs are emerging
in Singapore
Although our city is a really very green
these add more interest and more charm
to the city
each architectural project is an
opportunity for me to contribute to our
built environment
creating something new and refreshing is
always a fun thing to do and it's most
rewarding when I see others enjoying
these creations
one of our recent project is the Gallup
extension to Singapore Botanic Gardens
this project is unique because other
land is about 8 hectare which is unusual
for Singapore
and the other unusual factor is that
it's a combination of two pieces of land
so our task is to stitch up these two
pieces of land and make it seamless so
that the visitor can enjoy the two very
contrasting and conflicting if you like
characteristic another project is the
bukatima railway station that we've
completed when we took over the project
we restore the two buildings the station
another one the master houses
we also introduce a running track to
continue along the stretch of bukitima
to allow the jogger to have a very
comfortable way of coming to the side
and enjoy the architecture at the same
time
I was really over the moon when I got
the news that I want the PDA although
over the years we've been getting
different prices and more this really is
Meaningful to me as a Singaporean it
shows that the work that we've been
doing in Singapore
are well appreciated